this is a production of Cornell
University
I'm an extension associate with the
Cornell waste management institute we're
part of the soil and crop sciences
section in the school of integrative
plant sciences here they changed the
name on us just to confuse things and
force us to update all our materials
eventually many of which still have the
old name but so I do have some slides
but I want to keep it really informal
and keep this intro part really brief so
that we have some time to talk about
concerns and ideas and interest from all
of your perspectives because it's really
useful for me to hear from some people
that I have been necessarily cross paths
would before and broadly I begin my work
with Cornell about eight years ago to
address concerns about soil quality in
soil contaminants and much of that work
has been through a collaborative effort
called healthy soils healthy communities
which I'll tell you a bit more about in
just a moment and so as I said I'd like
to give you a brief overview of our
research and extension outreach
resources and programs but then more
importantly spend some time
brainstorming a little bit how we might
be able to all work together to address
some needs and concerns and it's always
helpful to hear any perspective so
healthy soils healthy communities has
been funded for a number of years by the
National Institutes of Health and the
National Institute of Environmental
Health Sciences that group that funding
has actually currently run out but it's
supported this program for a number of
years this partnership was led by
Cornell together with the State
Department of Health and a number of
partners in New York City including new
york city parks and recs greenthumb
program as well as other partners in New
York City Buffalo and elsewhere across
the state and broadly the goal of this
research was to help understand more
about levels of contamination and urban
gardens and farms and then what that
might mean for possible exposures and
health risks and to inform our
understanding of how we can recommend
affordable and feasible healthy
gardening practices so we don't want to
just point out to people that there's a
problem we want to focus on
feasible strategies that they can
implement in their own gardens or yards
so this healthy soils program was
focused on urban community gardens more
specifically but a lot of what we've
learned carries over to rural areas
residential properties we don't just get
questions from urban gardeners even
though that was the focus of this part
of the study
you all know gardening and farming have
many many benefits you know everything
from source of healthy food to physical
and mental health benefits community
building all of these really great
things that I don't need to get into of
this crowd because you're all well aware
of them so we want to keep those
benefits in mind but the reality is is
that there are also risks at times years
of human activity have sometimes left
contaminants in soils in many areas we
don't have enough information about
levels of contamination and what might
be going on and sometimes gardening and
farming activities and any other
activities you know recreational
activities anything that could increase
contact with the soil may also bring
people in contact with the contaminants
and we kind of jokingly call this guy
exposure man just to give you an idea of
the possible ways that people can come
in contact with contaminants in their
environment they may be eating products
that are grown in soils such as
vegetables or chicken eggs they may be
accidentally breathing in or swallowing
so loyalists they're working in the
garden their skin may be touching soil
and then little kids of course also may
be eating soil may be playing in the
soil we want to think about all these
pathways for people contacts will this
work and my job here and our extension
focus have really come out of lots of
questions that we get from gardeners and
homeowners and County educators and in
others should people test their soil
does the site history matter does the
location matter all of these questions
if so how should they collect soil
samples and there's really no single
strategy to do that so we can help
people think through the decision-making
at the early end when they're just
thinking about sampling where should
they send the samples different labs
offer different services and different
educational materials sometimes none at
all watch of the results mean it doesn't
help to have numbers unless that can
help us turn that into some kind of
action and help the people that we work
with take some type of meaningful
feasible action and what should
gardeners do what should homeowners do
and that's really the focus of how can
our research efforts inform our
understanding and best practice
and strategies that people can do to
reduce their contact with little
contaminants and through the healthy
service projects basically we've sampled
contaminants in our environment in the
number of different ways everywhere from
the soils of gardens and farms to the
vegetables that grew in those soils to
the chicken eggs that were raised in
some of these urban farms and gardens
and that helps us understand more about
the contact that people have with this
that can then inform these best
practices that we've been referring to
which can then inform our future
research and help us figure out places
where we might need more information and
I'm not going to get into all of the
science or all the details here but
broadly our 10 best practices for
healthy gardening resource is a
half-sheet handout that gives an
overview of kind of the take-home points
of all of this use clean soil and
compost use raised beds or grow in a
clean medium whenever possible avoid
treated wood certain types of wood can
contain contaminants that are a health
risk cover or mulch or soil maintain
soil nutrients and pH put a barrier
under play areas keep an eye on children
to be sure they're not just ingesting
handfuls of soil basic hygiene practices
like leaving your soil in the garden
washing your hands washing and feeling
produce can make a big difference and
again we have a variety of resources
that get into the details of all of this
and I'm happy to answer more questions
but just to give you a taste of how that
all this works here's an example of some
of our research findings that have
informed our understanding of best
practices so for example from our
research in New York City community
gardens through our data we have seen
that average lead levels are lower in
gardens that have more raised beds as
opposed to growing in the ground so that
shows us that these recommendations are
on target and that we are actually
seeing results from people growing and
raised beds clean material rather than
growing in grand soil that in many cases
can be contaminated adding
helps lower lead levels and helps to
bind blood in the soil to make it less
available to plants we work a lot with
compost added benefit to that is of
course that compost is great for
gardening in general and there are many
other benefits aside from just the
considerations for contamination we
recommend that gardeners keep their
soils and you're neutral for most crops
and as behind that recommendation is
this is what we've seen that at lower pH
led is in a more available form in soil
that means that is the ph is lower it's
more likely that lead can be taken up
into plans but the good news is is that
for lead it's actually physical
contamination by saleal particles not
uptake through the roots that likely
accounts for most of the lead and
vegetables so it's good news that plants
are good at keeping lead out of their
tissue and that means that there are
other things we can do to keep dust and
soil particles off of plants like
mulching and washing them thoroughly and
designing our garden so that we have
fewer areas of bare soil blowing around
on our plans and crop type matters of
the results of all the vegetable testing
we did in New York City and Buffalo
gardens we see lower levels of lead and
other contaminants overall in fruiting
crops fruits and vegetable fruits roots
and leafy greens can be more affected by
contamination because the roots are
growing directly in the soil and the
leafy greens can be more affected by
those sort of particles and could be
different that can be difficult to wash
off of them where's a lot of fruiting
crops you can wash them more easily and
the plant has even more natural barriers
to keep the contaminants out of the part
that we eat so that can be another
useful tool if people are dealing with a
challenging contamination situation
this is the house to hand out that I
mentioned this is what it looks like
this is available on our website for
download in English and Spanish and
we're working on developing other
resources that are kind of short and
sweet like this our other fact sheets
are a little bit longer and more
involved in tend to be a good resource
for people that are looking for more
detailed science and more detailed
information and some of those are a
series of fact sheets that guide people
through thinking about sources and
impacts of contaminants and soils guide
to soil testing and interpreting results
best practices for healthy gardens is
kind of the longer version of the short
half sheet that I just showed you as our
newest resource which is called metals
in urban garden soils and that gives the
same healthy gardening tips but also
gives detailed information for the
elements most the metals most commonly
of concern for human health and plant
health so lead as well as about eight or
so others and including guidance values
that can help people understand what
their test results mean and what they
should compare them Q to make informed
decisions and just some other resources
many of you may be familiar with the New
York State's healthy gardening brochure
can see this pictured here and that's a
great resource they're happy to send
them to folks they have lots of copies
printed so there's a way to order them
through the doah website if you're ever
looking for those to hand out to people
that can use them and EPA has some great
resources as well and through the eight
or so years that we've been working on
this project we've seen more and more
information becoming available from
federal agencies and other research
programs love to hear more about what
types of questions you get in your
counties whether you feel like you have
the information and resources that you
need if there are specific things that
you'd like to see from us we would love
to hear that you know as I mentioned
we've heard that there's a need for more
shorter resources more multimedia things
that are a little more digestible than
fact sheets for certain audiences which
is definitely a fair point is something
we're working on and also it would
really be great if anyone has ideas for
making connections across New York State
to share
formation and successes and make sure
that we're sharing whatever resources
people have I get a quick view questions
rather about pressure treated lumber and
seems like there's a I don't know if
this is a unique here but this is we've
had a fair bit of pushback recently
about about that well there's you know
there's no proof that it's you know that
the new compounds are toxic and so on
and is there a Cornell publication that
you know gives some guidance in writing
there that we could go to people well
you know since it's not proven safe we
suggest that you you know not use it or
something until we get better you know
some some studies come in I am not aware
of a specific resource that gets into
the chemicals that are currently in
pressure treated lumber as many of you
know that concern for many years was the
CCA treated lumber that had copper
chromium and arsenic in it all of which
are not a great idea from the human
health perspective that our position
with the current treated lumber is that
we don't have any research showing that
it's harmful but we also don't have any
research showing that it's safe so to
err on the side of caution would be to
use a non treated and untreated
alternative if that's possible so number
three as avoid treated wood but we don't
get into the details of why and part of
that is that this sheet is very basic
but we don't specifically named the
chemicals in the new treated wood or get
into why there a problem in some of our
longer documents we've explained what
the problem was with CCA treated wood
but the more years we get out from that
being a circulation that's becoming a
little less relevant so I agree that
maybe it's time to update one of our
longer resources to comment more
specifically and I mean would it still
be useful even if it just said something
like we don't have evidence that it's
safe or is that just a cop out you know
that that's sort of the balance is with
a lot of these issues we don't
necessarily
have answers or complete research-based
information so it's a in terms of
putting things in writing it's a little
bit of a balance of when do we feel
confident enough that we can share
something without adding to the
confusion versus areas that just truly
need more research and therefore we're
kind of waiting until we see some
results to fine-tune some of our
recommendations and but that but that
one about treated wood I mean that
question of whether chemicals and
current treated wood are toxic is not
something that our research group will
be prepared to handle any time soon so
it may be that we just do need some
language to give people more specific
advice now another question related to
pressure-treated is if we're not going
to use pressure-treated are there other
species we want I recommend that yeah
we've had good luck with locust if
that's available where your gardeners
are where you are that's not always an
option for everyone I mean untreated
lumber can work though it isn't going to
last quite as well as as other options
you know something like cedar could work
we could possibly pick apart the
sustainability of that but again I know
here in Ithaca local locally sourced
locust has been a great alternative for
something that's a little tricky to work
with initially because it is so hard but
once you've got the beds in place
they've been holding up really well and
that's one thing that we would like to
do more of as well is to work with
counting educators and others to have
resource lists for particular locations
for things like bed building supplies
and soil and compost and all of these
things that seem so basic from the short
version of our recommendations like how
did you conceal and compost well that's
great as long as you have a source that
is reliable and may not be contributing
to a contamination concern and yes use
raised beds is a very oversimplified
recommendation people want to know what
type of wood how high they should be you
know specifically what should they be
doing
some of that is really going to be
situations dependent and that there
there should be room for flexibility
based on the needs of a particular site
but I agree that it would that more
tutorials more workshops would be
helpful for everyone and we're hearing
from people that they would like more
details for all of these recommendations
I know it's really hard to come up with
specific guidance on soil testing but I
would love to see more kinds of tools
like a flowchart related to helping
decision-making based on site history
intended use and budget does anything
like that exists it exists in our head
that's actually something we've thought
a lot about it a flowchart or almost
like a decision to reformat that's
easier to navigate than a fact sheet so
yes we agree with you that that would be
really helpful we haven't made it happen
yet but that is definitely something
that's on our radar so if you have any
specific ideas for components that would
go into that and that you'd like to see
please feel free to pass them along
because that is something that we are
kind of on the back burner at the moment
vote I would love to see that happen we
get questions regarding salt water over
wash from Hurricane sandy there were
home heating oil spills from flooding so
contamination do the weather related
episodes some so we get question of
whether it's safe to plant vegetables on
their property now three years later
yeah we had gotten a lot of questions
following Hurricane sandy as you might
imagine because we work closely with a
number of gardeners and organizations in
New York City I don't have the specific
resources in front of me but we do
actually have some information written
up that I would be happy to share if
that would be helpful the gist of it
basically was that given time the soil
should be able to recover from the salt
and the thing to be concerned about
would be if there were noticeable signs
of something like an oil spill so no an
oily residue in the soil or a chemical
smell either petroleum smell or evidence
that some sort of other chemical
had made its way into the garden as a
result of the flooding depending on the
specifics of what was there I could
consult with my team to see about what
we're looking at three years later so
kind of just the basic oh we've had
we've had a lot of salts it's very
likely that systems are in good shape by
now if there was a more specific
contaminant spill that could possibly be
something that could be addressed
through testing and bringing clean
materials in figuring out exactly what's
going on if that hasn't happened yet but
I'd be happy to talk further and share
what we had shared with gardeners at the
time getting questions about soil
pesticide contamination and residue any
information you have related to helping
ease people's concerns about that sure
so pesticides is a really broad category
of potential issues one thing that's
been on our radar a lot is the past use
of lead arsenate on former orchard plans
especially and also some different types
of growing areas but yeah we've actually
done a lot of research here at the
dillman Hill student farm on campus
which is a which was an orchard site in
the past and was heavily impacted by LED
arsenate contaminations so highly
elevated levels of both lead and arsenic
which bad news for students far but has
actually turned into a really great
piece for the opportunity and the staff
and students at the farm have worked
with us and others over a number of
years now to be sure that they're
growing food in areas that are not
impacted by the contamination and we've
been able to learn a lot for our own
projects by taking advantage of this
site that was impacted by this
historical contamination so that's one
specific example of one type of past
pesticide use that has had lasting
repercussions and that's kind of a big
one because there's a lot of former
orchard land that's now being used for
gardening and other purposes and farming
we kind of think about identifying
contaminant problems as detective work
so Paul thinking about
cific alee what may have happened on a
set on a site sometimes we know exactly
hey this gardener or this landscaper
came in and applied this particular
product what does this mean and in that
case you can look up the material safety
data sheets you can possibly test for a
particular chemical in other cases it's
more of a vague understanding that may
beat something viewed in the past in
general we recommend testing for metals
as a starting point if there are
possible concerns about contamination so
if there were lead arsenate used that
would show up in the form of lead and
arsenic testing for organic pesticides
for example gets very expensive very
quickly so we don't generally recommend
that people test for other specific
contaminants beyond metals unless they
really have cause to think that it's an
issue with their site in some specific
question that they think the testing can
help with otherwise what might be a
better alternative is to put the money
that they would have spent on testing
into getting clean materials and
possibly just covering up the known or
suspected problem at a given site that's
not always possible but it's also not
always possible for someone to spend
hundreds or thousands of dollars on soil
testing particularly in a residential
situation so it's kind of a trade-off of
considering what we know about this site
what's likely to be a problem what
resources are available including money
and then figuring out the balance of
okay it should be focused on testing to
learn more which is that deal or do we
just put that money into implementing
best practices that can reduce contacts
with the contaminants even if they may
be buried under kind of the working
surface a
so that's really where this 10 best
practices for healthy gardening emerged
out of that thought of like how can we
be make best use of our resources
definitely and in a cost-effective way
site remediation meaning actually
removing contaminated soil is very
rarely an option for a lot of the
gardener's that we work with because if
you think about it you've you know
you've got to have the money to bring in
the equipment to get the soil out of
their son got to go to a landfill
especially in New York City logistics of
moving things and transport could be
really daunting so what often makes more
sense is to instead cover up the
contamination and just start fresh so if
you're growing food that often means
raised beds or you know putting some
type of barrier down and then bringing
in clean material you know a framed bed
can work a mound of clean soil over a
surface that's you know that's blocking
off the contaminated material can also
work so it's it's difficult to give very
specific recommendations because as I
said before a lot of sites can benefit
from flexibility of finding what works
for them but these are kind of the basic
principles that we want people to keep
in mind if the pH is very different than
the normal surrounding soil should be
eat or you know are there any like hints
that there might be heavy metal
contamination it's like any red flag
testing that you can do this
less-expensive not really is the tricky
part you know for example we can see
plants thriving and soils that are very
high and lead because that is not toxic
to plants the way it is to people if
certain metals are our phytotoxic but
those don't tend to be the same ones
that are a concern for human health the
what we find most helpful is thinking
about the most common sources of
contaminants so for lead lead paint is
really a big one in both urban and rural
areas so if the if a garden or soil of
any kinds is adjacent to an older
painted structure that would have had
blood pain at some time in the past it's
very likely that there may be elevated
levels of lead
closest to that structure we tend to see
the highest levels right by the building
and then it decreases from there
sometimes there was an old out building
on the site you know an old garage or an
old shed or something that would have
been painted and that building make it
taken down and the current owner may not
even remember that that had been there
or know that it had been there but if we
were to test the whole site we may see
kind of this legacy of that past pain
LED from leaded gasoline was also a big
impact on lead levels so places closer
to busier roadways can be impacted by
LED specifically and then also the lead
arsenate from pesticide use and the
possible sources are a little different
for each of the different metals in our
fact sheets you can read more about
specific contaminants and where they may
have come from but it's you know kind of
so for led you can't see it or smell it
for organic contaminants you know if you
smell something that doesn't seem quite
right if you see an oily residue that
might be evidence that something was
going on if you know that burning had
happened at a site known old burn barrel
could give you a clue that that might be
an area to pay attention to but other
than these types of clues and trying to
parse out the site history unfortunately
there aren't there generally aren't easy
ways to look at the soil or look at the
plants and know that there's a problem
unless you see a pool of oil or smell
something but that's kind of an extreme
case
we're always looking to hear from people
the more we hear from people the more we
can make a strong case that we should
exist and that our program should be
here so you know where we're happy to to
hear in Currys directly from you please
pass along questions from people you
work with in your counties that you know
that we may be able to help answer you
know please please make use of us so
that we can continue to exist and be
here thank you everyone
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu